how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder
well it is now once again a really great
time in the marvel community because we
are finally getting marvel content
after coven 19 shut down the production
of all of marvel studios's projects we
went through
a little bit of a dry spell there with a
lot of marvel's phase 4 projects being
pushed back including black widow being
pushed back to november
but the dry spell is over as last night
we got the wanda vision trailer if you
haven't checked out my breakdown of it
i'll link it up above
but a big question that a lot of people
are still asking even after the trailer
is when
exactly is the series going to release
disney plus did in fact announce that it
is coming this year
but what month well thanks to a recent
discovery as it turns out we may be
getting it
sooner than we thought also is the
falcon and the winter soldier still
going to come out before the one
division series
well luckily for us disney plus and
marvel have answered a couple of these
questions
and it looks like we have figured out
one of them on our own as well
and i'll break it all down in this video
but first big congratulations to youtube
user braden kerr for being the winner of
last week's thanos funko pop giveaway
just shoot me an email in the email in
my description and we'll get you your
prize
and for this week to celebrate the
release of the wanda vision trailer
we'll be giving away
a scarlet witch funko pop all you gotta
do to enter subscribe like the video and
leave a comment down below
now to start it all off unfortunately
marvel and
disney plus have given us the answer of
when we can expect the falcon and the
winter soldier
marvel and disney have recently updated
the falcon and the winter soldier
homepage on disney plus and
unfortunately it is now updated to say
2021
so sadly the falcon and the winter
soldier has been delayed till next year
and that's a huge bummer but we know
that they have to finish up some filming
which means they'll have to do some
editing as well so it doesn't come as
that big of a surprise but
fortunately we are getting wanda vision
but now of course the question
is when now if you look at the one
division page on disney plus it says
december 2020 however
it is said december of 2020 since
february of this year so
it's not updated which is actually good
news because
disney has already confirmed that we are
getting it in 2020 so that means it
could come
before december so we could get it
earlier and it looks like somebody has
figured
it out new evidence found by the guys
over at murphy's multiverse.com points
to the show being released on november
27th of this year
now how they found this information out
is actually pretty cool
now there's a section of data on each
show and movie page that lists release
dates currently set by the provider
which is disney plus now in this code
murphy's multiverse has found the part
where it says release date and it does
say
november 27th and this was recently
updated on september 18th
right before the trailer for the one
division series went out
and to top it all off they checked the
same data for the mandalorian since the
mandalorians release date has already
been announced and
lo and behold in the data it does say
release date
october 30th 2020 which is the actual
release date that disney announced so
according to this evidence that has been
found it does seem pretty
likely that november 27th is going to be
the release date for the one division
series
and since the one division series was
supposed to air in december of 2020 this
isn't really that far off
november 27th is only three days away
from december so it looks like black
friday could be the release of the one
division series
now another thing that people have been
asking is what about the continuity of
black widow
the falcon in the winter soldier and the
one division series well one of the
potential reasons that the falcon and
the winter soldier could have been
pushed back is the release date of black
widow there have been reports that
marvel studios is considering moving
black widow's release date and many
people do expect that black widow is
going to have some setups for the falcon
and the winter soldier that means that
black widow will indeed have to come out
before
falcon and the winter soldier but as far
as its connection to the one division
series it doesn't look like there's
going to be much
because marvel wouldn't have one
division coming out before black widow
or the falcon and the winter soldier if
it gave anything away
or set anything up all we know right now
is that the wanda vision series
for sure is going to set up the events
of doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness so as far as continuity goes
that's all that really matters at this
point in time so the one division series
coming out before black widow
and before the falcon in the winter
soldier is perfectly fine don't worry
marvel studios knows what they're doing
so bummer to hear about the falcon in
the winter soldier but good news we are
getting the one division series
this year and we could be getting it on
black friday
so be sure to let me know what you think
about this news in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news for live updates
and stupid memes you can follow me on
twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you